>> PREVIOUSLY...
ON AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
ON A GO-SEE RACE
AROUND SYDNEY,
BRITTANY'S TEMPER
GOT THE BEST OF HER,
AND SHE WAS DISQUALIFIED.
>> STOP TELLING ME
NOT TO BE UPSET!
I CAN BE UPSET IF I WANT TO.
>> IN THE PHOTO SHOOT,
THE GIRLS
HAD TO SELL THEIR LOOK
FOR MEN AND WOMEN.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> NICE.
>> OH, MY GOD. THAT LOOKS HOT!
>> DESPITE HER TALENTS
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
BRITTANY'S PRESENCE
FAILED HER...
NONE OF THE CLIENTS SAID THAT
THEY WANTED TO BOOK YOU--
NOT ONE OF THEM.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
FOUR GIRLS REMAIN--
DIONNE, RENEE,
JASLENE AND NATASHA.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
"SOME OF YOU BELIEVE THAT
YOU ARE BORN TO BE A TOP MODEL,
BUT I SENSE THAT
ONLY ONE WILL HAVE THE HEART,
SOUL AND SPIRIT
TO MAKE IT TO THE TOP.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> I DON'T GET IT.
CAN'T EVEN PUT A FINGER
ON WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
MY MIND IS JUST SO FAR GONE.
I'M TIRED.
I CAN'T EVEN THINK ABOUT
WHAT THIS TYRA MAIL MEANS.
SO I WAS LIKE,
WHATEVER HAPPENS, HAPPENS.
I'M FENNA TAKE MY ASS TO SLEEP.
>> DID YOU THINK
BRITTANY WAS GOING HOME TODAY?
>> NOT UNTIL WE GOT INTO PANEL.
>> CAN YOU BELIEVE
THE FINAL FOUR IS THIS GROUP?
>> LAST PANEL,
MYSELF AND BRITTANY
WERE IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
THEY SAY THAT I DO THIS THING
CALLED "SCOWLING" A LOT,
WHICH MEANS THAT
I LOOK MEAN ALL THE TIME.
I DON'T KNOW
THAT I'M DOING IT.
IT'S JUST THERE.
>> WHEN YOU GET
IN FRONT OF PANEL,
WHEN THE PICTURE COMES UP--
WHEN IT GETS, LIKE,
REALLY SILENT,
AND THEY DON'T SAY ANYTHING--
>> THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW
YOU GOTTA GET UP. (laughs)
>> THAT--YEAH.
THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW THAT
IT'S COMING TO YA. (laughs)
>> 'CAUSE THEY'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT
WHY THEY DON'T LIKE IT,
YOU KNOW?
>> MM-HMM.
(wolf howls)
♪♪♪
(phone rings)
>> Hey, baby.
>> BABY.
>> I love you, baby.
>> HEY.
>> Well, I'm glad you called.
I've been worried about you.
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> How's everything doing?
>> BABY, I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
>> I love you, too, baby.
>> I'M GONNA BE SOON
NEXT TO YOU.
(sultry voice) BABY.
>> (laughs)
>> (singsongy) NATASHA'S CRAZY.
SHE'S PSYCHOPATHIC.
(normal voice) IT WAS LIKE
MAKING OUT WITH A PHONE
WITH HER HUSBAND ON IT.
(whispers) SHE'S WEIRD.
>> BABY.
(crying)
>> THESE GIRLS--THEY ARE
VERY, VERY INTO MY BEHAVIOR.
EVERY MOVE I DO,
THEY WATCH ME.
I'LL LOOK AT YOU
WHEN YOU'LL CALL YOUR HUSBAND.
>> I DEFINITELY DON'T NUZZLE
THE PHONE.
>> (laughs)
GIRLS LITTLE BIT INTIMIDATED
BY MY LOOK.
I'M SUCH A STRONG COMPETITION,
THAT NO MATTER WHAT I WOULD DO,
THEY ALWAYS WOULD JUDGE IT.
♪♪♪
>> IT IS FREAKIN' RAINING.
THE WIND IS BLOWING
EXTREMELY HARD,
AND WE'RE FREEZING COLD.
>> I'M GETTING REAL COLD.
>> I KNOW.
>> LOOK AT HER IN HER HEELS.
>> (laughs)
>> YOU'RE GONNA GET, LIKE,
REALLY SICK, NATASHA.
>> I KNOW.
>> NATASHA'S WEARING WEDGE HEELS
TO GO CLIMB ROCKS
AND WALK THROUGH
A BUNCH OF BRANCHES.
COME ON, GIRL.
I KNOW YOU CAN GIVE THOSE A REST
JUST FOR A DAY LIKE THIS,
YOU KNOW?
>> WELCOME, LADIES.
MY NAME IS DULUMUNMUN,
BUT PEOPLE CALL ME UNCLE MAX.
>> NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> STORYTELLING IS A BIG PART
OF ABORIGINAL CULTURE.
WE'VE PASSED STORIES ON,
GENERATION BY GENERATION,
THROUGH WORD OF MOUTH,
BODY ART
AND THROUGH DANCE.
>> THESE YOUNG LADIES
ARE GONNA SHOW
YOU YOUNG LADIES A DANCE.
SO WE WANT YOU
TO LOOK AT THE STORY
THAT THEY'RE GONNA TELL YOU
IN THE DANCE.
AND THEN YOU CAN PERFORM
YOUR DANCE
SO THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND
YOUR JOURNEY.
>> THIS TEACH IS
ALL ABOUT TELLING A STORY,
AND I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S RELATED TO MODELING.
>> (singing in Aboriginal
language)
>> MODELS ARE STORYTELLERS.
WHETHER IT'S
YOUR OWN PERSONAL STORY
OR A STORY
THAT A DESIGNER'S
TRYING TO GET ACROSS,
WE TELL STORIES.
THEY TELL THROUGH DANCE.
WE TELL THROUGH PICTURES
AND RUNWAY.
>> (singing in Aboriginal
language)
>> OKAY.
WHEN SOMEONE SAYS "DANCE,"
YOU AUTOMATICALLY ASSUME,
LIKE, "SHAKE THAT, ALL THIS"
DANCE.
THEN WHEN I SAW THEM
PICKING UP BERRIES
AND FOOD AND FRUITS,
I DID GET A VISUAL UNDERSTANDING
THAT IT WAS GONNA BE MORE OF,
LIKE, AN ACTING-TYPE DANCE.
>> HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY!
HEY!
>> TODAY YOUR CHALLENGE IS
TO CREATE YOUR OWN STORY
THAT BEST DEFINES YOU.
YOU WILL USE BODY ART,
MOVEMENT AND ORAL SPEECH
TO TELL YOUR STORY.
WE'VE INVITED YOUNG GIRLS
FROM THE COMMUNITY
TO COME AND WATCH.
SO HOPEFULLY
YOUR STORIES WILL INSPIRE THEM.
CARISSA ROSENBERG
FROM "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE
WILL BE JUDGING YOU.
>> YOU'VE GOT 15 MINUTES
FOR YOU TO GO AND PREPARE
AND SHOW US A STORY.
BEST OF LUCK. GO.
♪♪♪
>> WE HAVE 15 MINUTES
TO GET OUR DRESS PAINTED
AND OUR BODY PAINTED
AND TO COME UP WITH A STORY.
WHEN I SEE THE DRESSES
THAT WE NEED TO WEAR,
I START SHAKING
JUST AT THE THOUGHT OF IT,
BECAUSE IT IS
SO UNBELIEVABLY COLD.
>> (shivering and moaning)
♪♪♪
>> I'M SO FREAKIN' COLD!
>> I'M NOT EXCITED
TO BE IN A DRESS
OUT HERE LIKE THIS,
BUT IF THOSE GIRLS
CAN DO IT FOR US,
I CAN DO IT FOR THEM.
HELLO. I'M NENE.
MY STORY IS
ABOUT WHAT MADE ME
WHO I AM TODAY.
WHEN I WAS YOUNG GIRL
AND I WAS DOWN HERE,
I WAS ABUSED,
AND SO I SHOWED THE PAIN
THROUGH THE BLOOD ON MY FEET.
AND AS I GET UP HERE,
IT STARTS TO DISPERSE,
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY FELT
NOTHINGNESS AT THIS POINT.
I WAS NUMB IN MY LIFE.
THERE WAS NO EMOTION FOR ME.
I HAVE FOUR SISTERS
AND ONE MOTHER.
THERE IS FIVE FLOWERS HERE.
WE GREW TALL AND STRONG
TOGETHER.
WE SUPPORTED EACH OTHER
THROUGH THE HARD TIMES.
MY HEART HERE IS WANTING
TO GIVE STRENGTH
TO THOSE WOMEN--
TO MAKE THEM STRONG,
TO STAND UP,
TO BE UNIFIED
AS ONE WOMAN SAYING "NO MORE."
MY TEARS SHOW THE PAIN
FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT KNOW HOW,
AND MY HEART IS BREAKING
FOR THOSE WHO STILL
WALK THROUGH THE ABUSE.
THANK YOU.
I SAW CARISSA SITTING THERE,
AND OBVIOUSLY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO IMPRESS HER
BECAUSE SHE'S
FROM "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE,
BUT I REALLY JUST
WAS MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT MY STORY WAS HEARD.
>> MY NAME IS JASLENE.
MY STORY IS,
I ONCE WAS A YOUNG GIRL
WHO WAS MISLED INTO PAIN,
AGONY AND SUFFERING,
AND MY ONLY WAY OUT
WAS THROUGH TRUE LOVE,
AND MY TRUE LOVE
WAS MY DREAM,
AND I FOUGHT
THROUGH SO MANY OBSTACLES
TO GET TO MY DREAM
THAT NOW I STAND HERE
SO IN LOVE,
SO HAPPY.
AND NOW ALL I DO
IS LIVE, LOVE AND LAUGH.
THAT'S MY STORY.
>> SIT. COME SIT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OH, GOD.
I DON'T WANNA DO NO DAMN DANCE.
FIRST OF ALL,
HOW THE HELL
DO YOU THINK I CAN DANCE
WHILE TELLING A STORY?
TELL WHAT STORY?
WHAT STORY DO YOU WANNA HEAR?
MY BOYFRIEND TRIES TO GET ME
TO DANCE WITH HIM
ALL THE TIME,
AND I JUST DO NOT DO IT.
I DO NOT WANT TO DANCE,
PERIOD.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO ME
IN THE PAST--
I MEAN, I DON'T FEEL
LIKE THAT'S RELEVANT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> (laughs)
I WAS LIKE, WHAT THE HELL?
I'M JUST GONNA MAKE THIS DANCE,
LIKE, 25 SECONDS,
AND I'M GONNA BE THROUGH.
THAT'S IT.
WHEN I WAS ABOUT 6 YEARS OLD,
MY MOM WAS SHOT,
AND SHE WAS PARALYZED
FOR ABOUT 15 YEARS NOW,
AND THIS LINE REPRESENTS
THE LINE THAT I WALK
TO REPRESENT
WHICH WAY SHOULD I GO--
IF IT WAS RIGHT
OR IF IT WAS LEFT.
AND THESE LITTLE DOTS
REPRESENT MY OLDER SISTER
AND HER TWO CHILDREN.
AND THIS ONE HERE REPRESENTS
MY SECOND OLDER SISTER
AND HER YOUNGER DAUGHTER.
AND THE LAST ONE REPRESENTS
MY BABY SISTER,
WHICH I LOVE THE MOST,
BECAUSE SHE'S THE ONE
THAT ENCOURAGED ME
TO REALLY PURSUE MODELING.
AND THIS YELLOW CIRCLE
REPRESENTS MY LIFE
AND WHAT I WANNA DO WITH IT--
TO PURSUE A CAREER IN MODELING
FOR MYSELF
AND FOR THIS PINK DOT
IN THE MIDDLE--
FOR MY BABY.
THAT'S MY STORY.
LET ME IN HERE.
>> (clears throat)
>> I'M SPEAKING QUIETLY,
BECAUSE I WANT EVERYBODY
TO PAY CLOSE ATTENTION
TO WHAT I'M DOING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE LOUD.
WHEN YOU SPEAK QUIET,
EVERYBODY'S LIKE, "HUH?"
>> I SEE HER LIPS MOVING,
BUT I DON'T HEAR A THING.
IT'S JUST LIKE...
(no audio)
I'M LIKE,
"WHAT THE HELL IS SHE SAYING?"
>> I HAVE NO CLUE
WHAT NATASHA'S STORY WAS.
I COULDN'T HEAR
WHAT SHE WAS SAYING.
SHE'S A SWEET GIRL,
BUT I JUST FEEL LIKE
SHE'S A FEW FRIES SHORT
OF A HAPPY MEAL.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
(normal voice) MY DANCE
IS REALLY GOOD
BECAUSE I USE THE TREE BRANCHES,
AND I'M BAREFOOT
LIKE THE GIRLS
WHO PERFORMED BEFORE ME.
>> IT'S GREAT
SEEING YOU GIRLS AGAIN.
>> HI.
>> IT WAS GREAT TO BE HERE
AND TO HEAR YOUR STORIES,
BECAUSE THE GIRL
THAT'S GONNA BE
ON THE COVER OF "SEVENTEEN"
IS GONNA HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO TELL HER STORY
TO 13 MILLION READERS,
AND IT'S PART OF BEING
A PUBLIC FIGURE.
PEOPLE WANNA KNOW
ABOUT YOU AND YOUR PAST
AND CONNECT TO YOU
ON DIFFERENT LEVELS.
AND THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE...
IS NENE...
BECAUSE I REALLY FELT LIKE
THE READERS OF "SEVENTEEN"
WOULD RELATE TO YOU
AND CARE ABOUT YOU
AND JUST, YOU KNOW, WANNA HEAR
WHAT YOU HAD TO SAY,
AND THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO ME.
YOU GET TO PICK ONE FRIEND,
AND YOU'RE GONNA GET
A VERY SPECIAL PRIZE.
>> OKAY.
>> WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO PICK?
>> I'M GONNA GO WITH JASLENE...
>> YAY!
>> BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
HER STORY WAS CLOSE TO MINE.
>> OH.
>> I PICKED JASLENE
TO SHARE MY PRIZE,
BECAUSE I FIGURED THAT
IF I'M GONNA SHARE A PRIZE,
I WANNA SHARE IT WITH SOMEBODY
THAT I REALLY GET ALONG WITH,
AND THAT WOULD BE JASLENE.
♪♪♪
>> HI, GUYS.
>> HI.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
HOW WAS YOUR DAY?
>> HI!
>> GOOD.
>> COME ON IN AND HAVE A SEAT.
>> (laughs)
>> WHO'S RENEE?
>> I'M RENEE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR WIN TODAY.
IT MUST BE FANTASTIC.
AND YOU MUST BE JASLENE.
>> YES.
>> AND CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU,
JASLENE, ON, UH,
BEING CHOSEN AS THE FRIEND.
>> THANK YOU, RENEE.
>> SO AUTORE--
UH, WE HAVE OUR OFFICE
RIGHT HERE IN SYDNEY,
AND WE ARE
ONE OF THE LARGEST DISTRIBUTORS
OF SOUTH SEA PEARLS
IN THE WORLD,
AND WE SELL OVER 600,000 PEARLS
A YEAR.
AND TODAY WE HAVE
SOME BEAUTIFUL PRIZES FOR YOU.
WE HAVE THIS MAGNIFICENT STRAND
OF SOUTH SEA PEARLS...
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> THAT HAS SOME CHAMPAGNES
AND WHITES
AND BEAUTIFUL GOLD COLOR.
>> I AM SO EXCITED
TO WIN JEWELRY.
THIS IS AWESOME.
AUTORE PEARLS ARE, LIKE,
THE TYPE OF JEWELRY
THAT ROYALTY WEAR.
IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS,
AND I AM SO GRATEFUL.
>> AND THIS ACTUALLY
HAS SOME PINK DIAMONDS...
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> IN IT.
>> THIS JEWELRY IS STUNNING.
I MEAN, STUNNING, LIKE, IT--
I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
OH, MY GOD!
>> ...THE AUTORE 2000.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> IT'S LIKE A DREAM COME TRUE.
REALLY.
(squeals)
OH, MY GOD. OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS THE BEST GIFT EVER.
>> AAH! (laughs)
>> THANK YOU SO, SO MUCH.
>> IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO WIN THESE CHALLENGES.
I DON'T KNOW WHY
I DIDN'T BOOST MYSELF UP
TO ACTUALLY TRY TO WIN THIS.
I DID TRY,
BUT I SHOULD'VE GAVE
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE.
I JUST THINK THAT
I'M AT THE POINT
WHERE I JUST REALLY
WANNA HAVE SOME FUN.
>> YOU WORK HARD.
YOU PLAY HARD.
IT'S--IT'S--YOU KNOW,
YOU HAVE TO BALANCE IT.
>> WE HAVEN'T BEEN ANYWHERE.
WE'VE BEEN COOPED UP.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING.
SO RENEE, JASLENE AND MYSELF
DECIDE THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO OUT.
♪♪♪
>> YOU FEELING SICK?
>> MM-HMM.
>> SO YOU'RE NOT GONNA COME?
>> NO, I'M NOT GONNA GO
WITH YOU GUYS.
YOU KNOW,
I'M VERY HAPPY THAT YOU,
UH, YOU WON THE PRIZE
AND YOU--
YOU'RE GONNA GO CELEBRATE,
AND I JUST FEEL VERY BAD.
>> YOU SHOULD PUT THAT ON
WHEN YOU TAKE A BATH.
'CAUSE THE STEAM WILL...
YOU SLEEP GOOD
WHILE WE'RE GONE, OKAY?
>> DIONNE,
I'M NOT GONNA GO WITH YOU GUYS.
>> THAT'S FINE.
NATASHA MAY HAVE THE FLU
OR A REALLY BAD COLD
OR SOMETHING
'CAUSE HER NOSE HAS BEEN RUNNY.
IT'S--IT'S JUST A--
SHE LOOKS A MESS.
♪♪♪
>> WE'RE SO EXCITED
TO ACTUALLY
GET OUT OF THE HOUSE.
WE'RE HAVING A NIGHT OUT.
>> I THINK WE WERE BETTER OFF
NOT HAVING NATASHA
COME WITH US.
SHE WAS THIS FUNNY RUSSIAN GIRL,
BUT NOW
SHE'S JUST ANNOYING TO ME.
>> YOU GUYS
BETTER REALLY BRING IT
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT TOMORROW.
>> WHOO!
>> DIONNE,
NONE OF THIS--NONE OF THIS
"NO CONTACT WITH THE CAMERA"
THING, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> WE NEED TO SEND SOMEONE HOME,
AND YOU GUYS ALL KNOW
WHO I'M TALKING ABOUT.
>> TO BE HONEST,
I DON'T SEE HER GOING HOME
RIGHT NOW.
SHE'S IMPROVING WEEK BY WEEK,
SO...
>> I WANNA SEE NATASHA GO HOME.
RIGHT NOW I'M OVER HER.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON WITH HER,
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
SHE GOT SOME LIES
FLOATING AROUND SOMEWHERE.
>> I'M REALLY CURIOUS AS TO
HOW DOES SHE LIVE HER LIFE,
LIKE, AT HOME WITH HER HUSBAND.
>> YEAH, 'CAUSE LIKE...
>> NATASHA DOESN'T
HAVE A WEDDING RING.
I'VE NEVER SEEN
A PICTURE OF HER HUSBAND.
PICTURES OF HER DAUGHTER.
I-I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S JUST CONFUSING FOR ME.
>> SHE DOESN'T TALK
ABOUT HER FAMILY, FOR REAL.
>> YEAH.
>> WE DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT HER HUSBAND AT ALL.
I DON'T KNOW EVEN KNOW HIS NAME.
>> HER STORY HAS CHANGED--
>> A MILLION TIMES.
>> YES! THAT'S THE THING.
IT'S LIKE, IF YOU'RE GONNA LIE,
AT LEAST BE GOOD AT IT.
>> THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE COMPETITION,
I'M TALKED ABOUT.
I'M IN... (laughs)
IN EVERY CONVERSATION.
THEY NICE TO MY FACE,
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT ME
TO KNOW THAT
THEY ARE FEELING JEALOUS.
I DIDN'T LET IT TOUCH ME,
BECAUSE IT WOULD DISTRACT ME
FROM THE COMPETITION
TO LET THESE GIRLS
GET IN MY HEAD.
>> ♪ HOME, SWEET HOME ♪
>> OH, WE GOT TYRA MAIL.
(laughs)
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> I'M GONNA READ IT. OKAY?
"SORRY, GIRLS,
YOU'RE HISTORY.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> "HISTORY"?
>> THAT WAS LIKE...
A STAB IN MY HEART.
>> WE'RE GONNA DO SOMETHING
FROM THE PAST?
>> HISTORY.
>> THIS PICTURE IS REALLY HOT.
>> TIME TO GO TO SLEEP.
♪♪♪
>> (blows nose)
TODAY I WOKE UP,
AND I WAS HAVING A FEVER.
I HAVE THE STUFFED NOSE
AND THE SORE THROAT,
TO THE POINT
WHEN IT'S REALLY, REALLY HARD
FOR ME TO SWALLOW.
I FEEL SO MUCH PRESSURE
BECAUSE THE COMPETITION
IS GETTING HARDER.
THERE ARE NOT MANY GIRLS LEFT,
AND I'M REALLY SCARED
THAT I'M NOT GONNA BE ROCKING
IN THIS PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
♪♪♪
>> HOW YOU GUYS DOING TODAY?
>> GOOD!
>> YOU EXCITED?
>> YES!
>> TODAY YOU'RE MEETING
WITH THE NGEMBA TRIBE,
AND EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
ARE GONNA BE ASSIGNED
A DIFFERENT STORY,
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO ACT OUT THAT STORY
IN YOUR PHOTO.
ISN'T THAT REALLY COOL?
>> YEAH.
>> I WANNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
HIS NAME IS KANE.
HE IS A FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
I THINK HE'S THE PERFECT PERSON
TO DO THIS SHOOT TODAY.
COME ON IN HERE.
>> MORNING, GIRLS.
>> HI.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> WELL, I THINK
TODAY'S GONNA BE, LIKE,
A REALLY COOL SHOOT,
SO I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE A GREAT DAY.
>> EACH OF YOU
ARE GOING TO BE ASSIGNED
ONE OF OUR LEGENDS
FROM OUR TRIBE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO INCORPORATE
ABORIGINAL CULTURE
INTO OUR PHOTO SHOOT.
>> EACH ONE OF YOU
WILL COME OUT ONE AT A TIME...
>> AND I'M, LIKE,
DO WE HAVE TO DANCE AGAIN?
>> YOU'LL HAVE
A STORY TO LEARN...
>> PLEASE TELL ME
WE DON'T HAVE TO DANCE AGAIN.
>> AND YOU'LL ALL HAVE
A DANCE TO PERFORM.
>> AND I'LL BE DAMNED.
WE HAVE TO DANCE AGAIN.
>> AND YOU'LL LEARN THAT
WITH US, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NO WORRIES.
♪♪♪
>> I THOUGHT THAT
I-I WOULD BE BETTER TODAY,
BUT I'M, LIKE, I'M NOT.
I'M STILL SICK.
>> STILL SICK?
>> UH-HUH.
REALLY, REALLY SICK.
>> (laughs)
>> OKAY.
THE DANCE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO LEARN
IS ABOUT THE RED BREAST ROBIN.
>> MY DANCE WAS, LIKE,
TURNING AND SHAKING MY KNEES
LIKE A CHICKEN.
I WOULD NEVER TAKE
THOSE MOVES BACK HOME.
WHATEVER HAPPENED THERE
STAYS THERE.
>> HAVE FUN WITH IT, YOU GUYS.
>> (laughs)
>> ALL RIGHT, JAY, YOU READY?
LET'S GO, GUYS.
YEAH. HOLD IT.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THAT'S IT.
GOOD.
(camera beeps)
>> OOH, I LOVE THAT INTENSITY.
IT IS GREAT.
>> YEP.
YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK THERE.
>> YEAH.
OKAY, THAT LOOKS GREAT,
BUT, JASLENE,
TIP YOUR HEAD DOWN.
'CAUSE WHEN TYRA AND I
GO THROUGH YOUR FILM
AND WE'RE LOOKING
STRAIGHT UP YOUR NOSE,
WE CAN'T USE THOSE PICTURES.
>> OKAY.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> OH, THAT'S GOOD THERE.
GOOD. HOLD THAT.
>> I LOVE HOW JASLENE PICKED UP
NOT ONLY THE SPIRIT
AND THE MOVEMENTS,
BUT SHE BROUGHT
HER OWN INTERPRETATION
THAT WAS REALLY BEAUTIFUL
AND GRACEFUL.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> LOOK AT YOU GUYS BACK THERE.
YOU'RE ALL PROS.
(laughter)
>> THEY LOOK LIKE
THEY WERE ALL TRAINED BY ME.
SO THIS IS DIONNE, EVERYBODY.
>> HI, DIONNE.
DIONNE, WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
WITH YOU
IS A FOOD GATHERING DANCE.
>> THE DANCE THAT SHARON
AND THE GIRLS TAUGHT ME
WAS ABOUT GATHERING.
SO ALL WE GONNA DO--
WE'RE GONNA CLEAN THE LAND
AND WE'RE GONNA LOOK AROUND
AND SHAKE THE TREES,
GET ALL THE BERRIES,
GATHER IT ALL UP,
GIVE THANKS TO GOD.
>> (speaks in Aboriginal
language)
>> AND THAT'S IT.
>> DIONNE,
IF THERE IS ONE THING I'VE SAID
WEEK AFTER WEEK AFTER WEEK,
WHAT IS IT?
>> STOP SCRU--LIKE,
MAKING THAT MEAN FACE.
>> THESE GROUP OF WOMEN HERE
HAVE A BEAUTIFUL ENERGY
ABOUT THEM.
SO I DON'T WANT YOU
TO BRING A SCOWLY ENERGY...
>> RIGHT.
>> AND MISREPRESENT
WHO THEY ARE, OKAY?
>> RIGHT.
IT'S THIS WAY.
>> ALL RIGHT. GREAT.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> HOLD THAT.
>> LOVE THE BODY LANGUAGE,
BUT GIVE ME MORE IN THE FACE.
>> MORE IN THE FACE.
>> YOU ALMOST GOT
MORE MEAN-LOOKING.
>> I DID?
>> YEAH, WHY?
>> I DON'T--I DON'T--
(laughs nervously)
>> JUST--YOU KNOW WHAT?
>> RELAX.
>> RELAX. DON'T OVERTHINK IT.
WORKING WITH DIONNE IS
ONE OF THE MOST
FRUSTRATING EXPERIENCES,
BECAUSE DIONNE
HAS A BEAUTIFUL SPIRIT,
BUT AS SOON AS DIONNE
STEPS IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
SHE STARTS TO LOOK
CONTROLLING AND MEAN.
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH THERE, TOO,
AGAIN.
CHIN DOWN A BIT.
NOW SMILE WITH YOUR EYES.
>> YEAH. REALLY POSITIVE.
GOOD ENERGY. GOOD.
GREAT.
>> SEE? THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
I HAD TO LEAVE
THE TRAINING WHEELS ON
AND COACH DIONNE THROUGH
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE SHOT.
GOOD.
SHE'S SMILING WITH THE EYES.
SO WHAT DANCE
IS NATASHA GONNA DO?
>> THIS ONE IS ABOUT
THE WIGGLY WAGTAIL.
>> MY DANCE IS ABOUT
THE WIGGLY WAGTAIL BIRD.
>> (singing in Aboriginal
language)
>> SO THIS BIRD
IS ALWAYS JUMPING
AND IS ALWAYS HAPPY,
AND IT'S A HAPPY DANCE.
(moans)
>> ALL RIGHT, JAY.
YOU READY?
>> YEAH, I'M--I'M COOL.
>> OKAY. LET'S DO IT.
>> (sniffles)
(coughs)
>> SHE LOOKS MISERABLE.
>> LET'S TRY TO LIGHTEN UP.
A LITTLE BIT HAPPIER, YEAH?
>> (sniffles)
>> YOU ALL RIGHT?
>> YOU KNOW THIS IS A REALLY,
REALLY IMPORTANT LESSON?
BECAUSE THERE WAS A TIME
I WAS IN ST. BARTHS WITH TYRA,
AND SHE WAS REALLY, REALLY SICK.
BUT AS SOON AS THE PHOTOGRAPHER
PICKED UP THE CAMERA,
TYRA LOOKED LIKE,
OOH, BAM! BAM! BAM!
SHE LOOKED LIKE A SUPERMODEL.
I KNOW YOU'RE NOT FEELING WELL,
BUT YOU NEED TO PUSH IT AWAY,
OKAY?
'CAUSE I CAN SEE IT HERE.
>> YEAH. OKAY.
>> OKAY?
>> MM-HMM.
I'M REALLY, REALLY SICK,
AND IT'S HARD TO HIDE.
BUT ALL I CAN THINK ABOUT
DURING MY PHOTO SHOOT
IS THAT I WANT
TO GO TO LAY IN THE BED
AND FORGET ABOUT EVERYTHING
FOR A--ONE DAY.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> NATASHA, THIS IS DO-OR-DIE.
WE'RE DOWN TO FOUR GIRLS.
>> UH-HUH.
>> I WOULD HATE TO SEE YOU THROW
THE WHOLE COMPETITION AWAY
BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T PUSH
THROUGH THIS ONE SHOOT.
>> (coughs)
>> SO I NEED YOU
TO TRY A LITTLE HARDER,
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
IT JUST LOOKS
REALLY, REALLY WEAK.
>> OKAY.
LET'S TRY THERE.
>> NOW LOOK UP.
>> HANG ON A SEC.
OKAY.
>> I'VE NEVER HAD A GIRL
JUST FALL THIS FLAT
AT THE END.
>> USE THE TREE. THAT'S GOOD.
>> (sniffles)
>> OKAY.
>> LAST FRAME.
COME ON, NATASHA!
ONE FRAME.
>> YEAH.
HOLD THAT. HOLD THAT.
>> (groans)
>> THIS DANCE IS ABOUT
THE FLIGHT OF THE BUTTERFLY.
IN OUR LANGUAGE,
WE CALL THE BUTTERFLY...
(speaks Aboriginal language)
>> (both speak Aboriginal
language)
>> I LEARNED
THE DANCE OF THE BUTTERFLY.
IT'S A VERY BEAUTIFUL DANCE.
I LOVE IT.
>> (singing in Aboriginal
language)
>> I SEE WHEN
THEY'RE TEACHING ME THE DANCE
A LOT OF WAYS I CAN WORK IT.
>> OKAY, RENEE.
HOLD IT.
BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S GOOD THERE.
>> PRETTY, RENEE.
>> GREAT, GUYS.
HOLD THAT.
>> MM-HMM.
>> YEP. GOOD GOING.
YOU'RE DOING REALLY GOOD THERE.
>> OH, THAT'S NICE, RENEE.
I LOVE THAT ASYMMETRY.
IT'S GREAT.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S GOOD THERE. YEAH.
>> CAN I DO ONE THAT'S NOT
EXACTLY LIKE THE DANCE?
CAN I MOVE IT A LITTLE BIT
FROM THE DANCE?
>> YEAH.
AS LONG AS YOU'RE STILL
BRINGING PART OF THAT DANCE,
THAT'S GREAT.
>> LIKE THIS?
>> YEAH. YEAH.
>> MAYBE IT'S
THE BUTTERFLY'S WINGS
GOING ALL THE WAY OUT.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> FULL EXTENSION HERE.
YEAH, THAT'S GOOD.
HOLD THAT.
>> OH, THAT'S GLORIOUS.
>> THAT LAST ONE WAS GOOD?
>> YEAH. IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
OOH, I LIKE THAT.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> NICE, RENEE.
LAST FRAME.
KILL IT FOR ME, RENEE.
THERE YOU GO.
>> I FEEL LIKE MY SHOOT
IS GOING TO IMPRESS TYRA.
I MADE IT VERY FASHION.
SO I JUST WENT FOR IT,
AND I FEEL LIKE
I GOT SOME KILLER SHOTS.
♪♪♪
>> IT'S TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY THREE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
DO YOU GUYS HAVE ANY IDEAS
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN TOMORROW?
>> UH--
>> UM...
>> I THINK WE MIGHT MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
>> UH, YEAH.
AND ONE OF US
IS GONNA BE ELIMINATED.
>> NUNH-UNH.
>> TOMORROW IS ELIMINATIONS,
AND TODAY WE HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
AND I DID A GREAT JOB,
THOUGH I FELT VERY BAD.
I'M VERY PROUD
I WAS ABLE TO GO
BECAUSE I DID FEEL
VERY, VERY SICK.
>> I JUST HOPE
NATASHA DOESN'T USE IT
AS AN EXCUSE,
BECAUSE THE JUDGES
WILL EAT HER ALIVE.
THERE'S BEEN PLENTY OF MODELS
WHO HAVE BEEN SICK
AND GONE TO WORK
AND GOT GOOD PHOTOS.
♪♪♪
(camera shutter snapping)
>> THE FINAL FOUR.
THE COMPETITION'S GETTING
REALLY, REALLY STIFF.
YOU ALL KNOW THE PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT,
ONE OF THE TOP MODELING AGENCIES
IN THE WORLD...
A 6-PAGE SPREAD AND A COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE, OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST--MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
RUNWAY DIVA COACH
EXTRAORDINAIRE,
COUNTING OUT THE GIRLS
RESTING IN PEACE
THAT HE IS REPRESENTING
WITH HIS RUFFLE-AGE...
TWIGGY,
LIVING LEGEND, FASHION ICON...
AND OUR GUEST JUDGE THIS WEEK--
CARISSA ROSENBERG,
THE ENTERTAINMENT DIRECTOR
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND, DIONNE, YOU'RE FIRST.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO EMBODY
DIFFERENT ABORIGINAL LEGENDS
THROUGH DANCE.
YOU WERE...
QUANDONG, THE FOOD GATHERER,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> THIS PICTURE'S
VERY, VERY STRONG.
I THINK IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> I'M JUST A LITTLE CONCERNED.
I DON'T SEE YOUR EYES LOOKING
AT ANYTHING IN PARTICULAR.
>> THAT'S BEEN A PROBLEM
WITH A LOT
OF DIONNE'S PHOTOGRAPHS,
ACTUALLY, IS THE EYE CONTACT.
>> ONE THING THAT I NOTICED
IN GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
THOUGH, IS WE TOLD YOU,
"DON'T BE MEAN. DON'T BE MEAN.
DON'T BE MEAN."
SO I SEE YOU GOING
FROM MEAN TO...
SO YOU HAVE TO FIND
A HAPPY MEDIUM
IN THERE SOMEWHERE.
I'M NOT GOING LIKE THIS...
AND I'M NOT GOING LIKE THIS...
BUT IT'S A...
ALL RIGHT, DIONNE, MR. JAY SAID,
WORKING WITH YOU IS FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE YOU SEEMED
TO GET POSSESSED AND LOOK
HARSH AND MEAN WHEN YOU GET
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
AND YOU STILL NEED
A LOT OF COACHING.
ALL RIGHT, DIONNE,
YOUR JUDGING TEST THIS WEEK
IS TO EVALUATE YOUR COMPETITION.
YOU GUYS ARE THE FINAL FOUR.
AND IN THIS WORLD OF MODELING,
COMPETITION IS EVERYTHING.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW
YOUR COMPETITION,
KNOW THEIR STRENGTHS
AND KNOW THEIR WEAKNESSES,
AND THAT'S HOW YOU GET AHEAD.
SO, DIONNE, WHO DO YOU THINK
HAS THE MOST TOP MODEL POTENTIAL
IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> I THINK I'M GONNA SAY JAS.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE
JAS' APPEARANCE.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST... STRIKING.
BUT I LIKE HER PERSONALITY.
I LIKE THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE HAVE TOGETHER.
>> AND WHO DO YOU THINK
HAS THE LEAST?
>> I THINK I'M GONNA
HAVE TO SAY NATASHA.
IT'S JUST, LIKE,
SOMETHING ABOUT NATASHA--
LIKE, HER PERSONALITY,
I FEEL LIKE
SOMETHING IS MISSING.
I-I JUST DON'T BELIEVE IT.
>> OKAY. ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS JASLENE.
FOR YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU REPRESENTED
THE RED BREAST ROBIN.
>> MM-HMM.
>> SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S VERY BEAUTIFUL,
BUT MY ONE THING ABOUT THIS
IS THAT THIS IS A FACE
THAT I'VE SEEN OF YOURS NOW
A LOT.
THIS STRIKING, STRONG FACE.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL, IT WORKS,
BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE
SOMETHING DIFFERENT FROM YOU.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, NIGEL?
THIS PICTURE REMINDS ME
OF YOUR EXECUTIONER SHOT.
IT'S A WEIRD THING
WITH BEING A MODEL THAT HAS,
LIKE, ONE STRONG LOOK,
BECAUSE YOU'LL GET BOOKED
FOR THAT AND, LIKE,
HAVE THAT SIGNATURE.
BUT THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF LONGEVITY IN THAT CAREER,
SO YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET DIFFERENT LOOKS.
ALL RIGHT, JASLENE,
WHO DO YOU THINK
HAS THE MOST POTENTIAL
OUT OF ALL YOU HERE?
>> I WOULD SAY ME,
JUST BECAUSE
I KNOW MOST OF THESE GIRLS
CAME IN HERE
JUST TO TAKE A CHANCE
OR JUST TO BE A PART
OF AN EXPERIENCE LIKE THIS.
BUT MY HEART, MY SOUL
AND MY SPIRIT
IS HERE AS WELL.
>> AND WHO DO YOU THINK
HAS THE LEAST POTENTIAL?
>> (sighs)
I LIKE NATASHA,
BUT TO BE HONEST,
I FEEL THE SAME WAY.
I RESPECT HER
AND I CARE FOR HER DEARLY,
BUT SHE COMES OFF REAL PHONY.
>> (whispers) OKAY, THANK YOU.
(normal voice) ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS RENEE.
RENEE WAS THE CHALLENGE WINNER
THIS WEEK.
>> DID YOU SEE MY PRIZE?
>> WHOO!
>> YES.
>> ALL RIGHT,
FOR YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU REPRESENTED
THE DANCE OF THE BUTTERFLY.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> IT'S VERY EVOCATIVE,
AND I LOVE IT.
>> YOU'VE ACTUALLY
FOUND THE LIGHT VERY WELL
WITH YOUR FACE AND YOUR EYES.
>> I THINK YOU LOOK
BEAUTIFUL AND STRONG,
AND YOU DEFINITELY
POP OUT OF THE PHOTO.
>> YES.
>> I WAS VERY PROUD OF YOU,
BECAUSE I-I THINK, POSE-WISE
AND THE AMOUNT OF CHOICES
THAT I HAD TO CHOOSE FROM,
YOU HAD THE MOST
OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS.
AND, RENEE, WHO DO YOU THINK
HAS THE MOST TOP MODEL POTENTIAL
OUT OF ALL OF YOU?
>> I THINK I HAVE
THE MOST TOP MODEL POTENTIAL.
I WANT TO TAKE MY FAMILY PLACES.
THEY ARE THE FIRE
THAT'S UNDER MY BUTT.
I WANT TO MAKE THINGS
GOOD FOR THEM.
>> WHO DO YOU THINK
HAS THE LEAST POTENTIAL
OUT OF ALL OF YOU?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO AGREE
WITH SAYING NATASHA.
I FEEL LIKE SHE PLAYS GAMES.
SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING LACKING
IN THE PERSONALITY.
I FEEL LIKE IT--
A LOT OF IT'S FAKE.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
(normal voice) ALL RIGHT,
LAST BUT NOT LEAST--NATASHA.
YOU WERE A WILLIE WAGTAIL.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> NATASHA, YOU HAVE
AN EXTREMELY STRONG LOOK
AND AN EXTREMELY STRONG FACE.
AND THIS IS A GOOD EXAMPLE
OF PUT THE WRONG MAKEUP ON YOU
AND IT DOESN'T SEEM TO WORK,
OR YOU'RE NOT CONNECTING
WITH IT.
>> IT JUST SEEMS A LITTLE
AWKWARD AND UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> AND I THINK,
SOMETIMES, WHEN ALL ELSE FAILS,
GO TO THE FACE.
JUST GET SOMETHING GOING
IN THE FACE
SO WE HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY...
IT--IT'S GREAT, AND, I MEAN--
>> IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT THE FACE.
>> YEAH.
>> THE FILM THAT I SAW
THIS WEEK OF YOU WAS WORSE THAN
YOUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
>> OOH.
>> I... IT WAS ALMOST LIKE
YOU WEREN'T READY
FOR ABOUT 90% OF THE SHOTS.
YOU'RE LIKE THIS...
LIKE THIS... THIS... THIS...
JAY LATER TOLD ME
THAT YOU WERE SICK,
BUT SICK DOESN'T MAKE YOU
GO LIKE THIS IN A PICTURE.
IT MIGHT MAKE YOU TIRED
OR KIND OF WEAK EYES,
BUT IT WAS...
LIKE YOU DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT YOU WERE DOING.
>> I HAD A FEVER BEFORE,
LAST NIGHT,
AND I PULLED MYSELF TOGETHER
ALL THE WAY
JUST TO COME TO THE PHOTO SHOOT
BECAUSE I FELT REALLY BAD.
>> MM, OKAY, UH, JAY SAID
THAT THOUGH YOU WORKED THROUGH
BEING SICK,
YOU DIDN'T PULL OFF YOUR SHOTS.
YOU SEVERELY REGRESSED
BACK TO YOUR INITIAL WEAKNESSES,
AND YOU WERE VERY AWKWARD.
I AGREE.
AND, NATASHA,
OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS HERE,
WHO DO YOU THINK HAS THE MOST
TOP MODEL POTENTIAL?
>> I HAVE THE MOST
TOP MODEL POTENTIAL
BECAUSE I DO HAVE THE FEATURES
THAT ARE IN FASHION RIGHT NOW.
I DO HAVE
EASTERN EUROPEAN FEATURES,
SO IT'S DEFINITELY 100% ME.
AND I'M VERY THANKFUL
FOR THE CRITIQUE
THE GIRLS, UH, JUST SAID.
I STILL LIKE THEM AND I STILL--
I--THEY ARE STILL MY FRIENDS.
>> I MUST SAY,
I'M COMPLETELY SHOCKED
BY THE REACTION
OF THE OTHER GIRLS.
BECAUSE SEEING YOU EVERY WEEK,
YOU ARE ONE OF
THE WARMEST GIRLS.
YOU MAKE US LAUGH.
YOU TAKE CRITIQUE.
AND SO TO HEAR WHAT
THEY WERE SAYING,
AND THEN I SUDDENLY THOUGHT,
WELL, YOU ARE
VERY, VERY BEAUTIFUL.
SO IS THIS A TRUTH COMING OUT
OR IS THERE A SLIGHT JEALOUSY
BECAUSE THEY THINK
YOU'RE AHEAD OF THEM?
I DON'T KNOW. IT'S VERY WEIRD.
>> IF GISELE BUNDCHEN
WOULD BE STANDING BEHIND ME
RIGHT NOW,
I'D SAY SHE HAS
THE LEAST POTENTIAL
BECAUSE SHE'D BE
THE BIGGEST, UH,
COMPETITION FOR ME.
>> HOW DOES IT FEEL
HEARING ALL THE GIRLS
SAY SUCH NEGATIVE THINGS
ABOUT YOU?
>> I FEEL LIKE
I'M ALWAYS BEING TALKED ABOUT.
LIKE, I WAS ALWAYS IN THE CENTER
OF ALL THE CONVERSATIONS.
BUT IT'S BETTER
TO BE TALKED ABOUT
THAN BE NOT NOTICEABLE.
>> OKAY. THANK YOU, NATASHA.
NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
IT'S GETTING DOWN TO THE WIRE--
FOUR GIRLS TO THREE TONIGHT.
♪♪♪
>> I TRULY WISH
EVERY ONE OF YOU LUCK.
YOU KNOW, GUYS, THAT I'M--
I--I'M JUST--THAT'S--
THE HOW I... I AM.
>> AT TIMES,
WE DON'T ACCEPT WHO YOU ARE.
>> IT SEEMS FAKE.
>> I'M NOT FAKE AT ALL.
>> WE'RE JUST LETTING YOU
KNOW AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE SEE FROM THE OUTSIDE
AND HOW YOU'VE BEEN WITH US.
>> I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU MEAN BY SAYING THAT.
I'M LIKE, OKAY?
>> I'M JUST DEFENDING MYSELF
AS FOR YOU SAYING
THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE PROBABLY JEALOUS.
NO, I'M NOT JEALOUS...
>> AH.
>> OR THAT IF WE
FIND YOU THREATENING.
NO, I DON'T FIND YOU
AS A THREAT.
SO I'M JUST SPEAKING
AS FAR AS THAT.
>> OKAY.
♪♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO WE'VE GOT FOUR GIRLS
BUT WE CAN ONLY END UP
WITH THREE TONIGHT.
SO WHO IS GOING HOME?
(camera shutter snaps)
>> DIONNE.
>> SHE, TO ME, HAS GIVEN
THE WEAKEST PHOTOGRAPHS
THROUGH THE COMPETITION,
ALTHOUGH THIS IS HER BEST,
I THINK.
>> SHE'S REALLY
A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
SHE JUST DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
A TOP MODEL TO ME.
>> ONE THING
THAT STUCK OUT TO ME IS
I ASKED EVERY SINGLE GIRL
WHO HAS THE MOST
TOP MODEL POTENTIAL,
AND DIONNE IS THE ONLY GIRL
THAT DID NOT SAY HERSELF.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> JASLENE.
>> JASLENE ALWAYS PRODUCES
GREAT PHOTOGRAPHS.
MY WORRY WITH HER
IS--IS SEEING THE SAME LOOK
OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> I THINK JASLENE IS THAT GIRL
THAT FEELS LIKE
THIS COMPETITION IS HER LIFE.
>> MM.
>> I LOVE FOR THE GIRLS
TO HAVE DRIVE, DETERMINATION,
"WANT THIS, BREATHE THIS,
LIVE THIS" TUNNEL VISION.
BUT IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN,
I'M NERVOUS FOR HER.
>> SO YOU'RE CONCERNED THAT
IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN, MENTALLY,
EMOTIONALLY, IT MAY DESTROY HER.
>> YES, AND SHE MIGHT
COME STALKING YOUR ASS.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> RENEE.
>> I LOVE THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
I THINK IT'S VERY STRONG.
HER FACE LOOKS GREAT.
>> EVERYONE LOVES RENEE.
RENEE IS DEFINITELY
A PRETTY GIRL.
SHE JUST DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
THE YOUNGEST, FRESHEST FACE
ON THE BLOCK.
>> YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW THIS,
BUT I HAD TO HOLD ALMOST, LIKE,
AN INTERVENTION WITH THE GIRLS
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL
SO AGAINST RENEE AT ONE POINT.
AND THEN THIS WEEK,
IT'S ALL ABOUT HATING NATASHA.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> IS THERE A JEALOUSY ELEMENT
IN THERE SOMEWHERE?
>> MM.
>> DON'T LOOK AT ME. I'M A GUY.
IT'S A GIRL THING.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
GUYS ARE JUST AS CATTY AND SHADY
AS GIRLS ARE.
>> MNH-MNH. NO.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> NATASHA.
>> I LOVE NATASHA.
I THINK THIS IS
HER WEAKEST PHOTOGRAPH.
BUT I BET--THINK SHE DEALT WITH
THE NEGATIVITY TODAY,
UM, MIRACULOUSLY.
>> I THINK WHAT NATASHA SAID
WAS RIGHT. SHE WAS LIKE...
(imitates Natasha)
"IF GISELE BUNDCHEN
WAS BEHIND ME, I WOULD SAY
SHE DIDN'T HAVE POTENTIAL, TOO,
BECAUSE I'D BE THREATENED."
(normal voice) YOU THINK
THE GIRLS ARE THREATENED?
>> THEY REALLY WERE
GANGING UP ON HER.
>> THEY WERE.
>> YEAH, THAT MIGHT BE,
BUT, YOU GUYS,
HER PHOTO SHOOT WAS A DISASTER.
>> MM-HMM.
>> FOUR OF YOU STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE THREE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE THREE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
RENEE.
CONGRATULATIONS, RENEE.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> THE JUDGES FELT YOUR PASSION
AND YOUR DRIVE,
AND YOU WANTING TO DO THIS
NOT JUST FOR YOURSELF
BUT FOR YOUR FAMILY,
AND THEY RESPECT THAT
AND LOVE THAT.
AND YOU DID A KICK-ASS PICTURE
AND YOU WON THE CHALLENGE.
>> YAY!
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
JASLENE.
ARE YOU SHOCKED?
>> YEAH.
I SO THOUGHT I WAS GONNA BE
IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
>> WHY?
>> YOU GUYS, YOU KNOW,
WANNA SEE A DIFFERENT EXPRESSION
AND I HAVEN'T BRUNG IT, SO...
>> YOU HAVEN'T "BRUNG" IT?
(laughter)
>> WELL, YOU NEED TO
"BRUNG-DID-DID" IT NEXT WEEK.
>> (laughs) I NEED TO BRING IT.
THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
WHAT THE JUDGES SAW WITH YOU
IS YOUR HEART.
>> I WANT THIS.
>> WE FEEL THAT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (whispers) THANKS.
>> (whispers) YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> (whispers) OH, MY GOD!
>> WILL DIONNE AND NATASHA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
♪♪♪
>> THERE'S TWO OF YOU BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME,
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOTEL,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO BACK HOME.
DIONNE,
YOU STARTED OFF ROUGH,
AND THEN YOU GOT BETTER
AND BETTER.
BUT THE JUDGES FEEL LIKE
YOUR ASCENT IS NOT LIKE THIS...
THEY FEEL IT'S LIKE THIS...
AND WHEN I ASKED
WHO HAS THE MOST
TOP MODEL POTENTIAL,
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE
THAT DID NOT SAY YOURSELF,
AND THAT WORRIES THE JUDGES.
'CAUSE IF YOUR PATH IS ROCKY
AND YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN
YOURSELF,
WHO'S GONNA BELIEVE IN YOU?
AND THEN WE HAVE NATASHA--
A GIRL WHO STARTED OFF AWFUL.
WE SAW THIS BEAUTIFUL FACE
AND GREAT PERSONALITY
THAT COULDN'T CAPTURE IT
ON FILM.
BUT SHE CONTINUED TO GET BETTER
AND BETTER AND BETTER.
AND THEN THIS WEEK COMES,
AND YOU COME DOWN WITH A COLD--
SICK--AND YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
WAS DREADFUL.
IT WAS WORSE THAN
YOUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
AND THE JUDGES GO,
THIS "SICK" THING
IS THE OLDEST "TOP MODEL" STORY,
AND WE ARE OVER IT.
AND ON TOP OF THAT,
WE ASKED EVERY SINGLE GIRL HERE
WHO HAD THE LEAST POTENTIAL,
AND THEY ALL SAID YOU.
WE DON'T LIVE IN THE HOUSE
WITH YOU ALL,
SO WE HAVE TO RELY, SOMETIMES,
ON WHAT THESE OTHER GIRLS
HAVE TO SAY.
IS THERE SOMETHING ABOUT NATASHA
THAT SHE'S HIDING?
IS SHE MANIPULATIVE?
IS SHE FAKE?
THERE'S GOT TO BE A REASON
WHY THESE GIRLS ALTOGETHER
HAVE BANDED AGAINST YOU.
>> NATASHA--
AND THE JUDGES THINK
MAYBE THEY'RE JUST JEALOUS.
♪♪♪
>> THIS COMPETITION IS NOT ABOUT
DOING ONE BAD PHOTO SHOOT
AND GETTING SENT HOME.
WE LOOKED AT YOUR BODY OF WORK
AND LOOKED AT DIONNE'S
BODY OF WORK AND FEEL LIKE
YOUR BODY OF WORK IS STRONGER,
AND THAT'S WHY
YOU STAND BEFORE ME.
BUT I GOTTA BE HARSH WITH YOU
AND SAY,
I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE SICK.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU HAVE A COLD.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU HAVE A FLU.
THIS IS FINAL THREE,
AND THERE'S NO MORE
SECOND CHANCES
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT.
>> I'M SO SHOCKED.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (in Russian) THANK YOU.
>> (whispers) OKAY.
>> YOU GOTTA
TAKE THE TRAINING WHEELS OFF,
'CAUSE THEY'RE STILL ON.
AND WE GAVE YOU ALL THE GOODS.
NOW IT'S UP TO YOU
TO LEAVE THIS COMPETITION
AND TAKE EVERYTHING
THAT WE TAUGHT YOU
SO THAT YOU CAN
BE ON A PHOTO SHOOT
AND NOT BE RESTING ON EVERYBODY
TO TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT TO DO.
OKAY?
ALL RIGHT.
♪♪♪
>> ALL I CAN SAY IS
THAT I'M JUST VERY DISAPPOINTED,
BECAUSE I KNOW I COULD'VE DID
A BETTER JOB.
>> BYE, DIONNE.
>> BUT I DID TRY.
I-I-I REALLY DID TRY.
GOING BACK HOME,
IT'S GONNA BE A BIG CHANGE.
I'M--I'M GONNA MISS
ACTUALLY GETTING UP EARLY
IN THE MORNING,
GETTING BEAUTIFIED,
PUTTING ON MAKEUP
AND GETTING MY HAIR DONE.
OF COURSE I'M GONNA MISS THAT.
I'M MAD THAT I FAILED,
BUT I STILL GOT A GOOD CHANCE.
I STILL HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SOMETHING
THAT PEOPLE DON'T NORMALLY DO.
I AM PROUD OF MYSELF.
♪♪♪
>> COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
>> WE'RE FINAL THREE!
>> THE FINAL THREE
TRY THEIR HANDS
AT A "MY LIFE AS A COVERGIRL"
SHOOT.
>> THIS IS AWESOME!
>> AND THE FINAL TWO
GET TO STRUT THEIR STUFF
AT A STUNNING FASHION SHOW.
WHOO!
ONLY ONE CAN BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
FIND OUT WHO
ON OUR SEASON FINALE.